各位你的手機越買越好
但你的APP真的有跟上手機嗎
今天這集我們找了5款手機上的神級AI黑科技
不誇張 這一集看完你的手機才算是真正解鎖了智慧這兩個字
嗨各位 又是我AJ
歡迎來到這個全新的系列 手機AI神器推薦
大家都愛講AI AI AI
但很多人手機拿起來除了滑IG還是不知道怎麽樣變強
所以我們之後 會固定整理3-5個裝在口袋里的AI神隊友
不管你是學生
上班族 還是想要利用通勤時間偷偷進化的狠角色
這集絕對能幫你省下時間 賺到技能
在開始之前先幫我訂閱 按讚 才不會錯過每一集的懶人包
話不多說我們就直接來看第一個讓我跪著用的工具吧
來第一個我們直接上主菜 Speak AI英文口說APP
沒錯這是大家手機8成都有裝的那個Speak
傳說中的Open AI的親兒子
也就是我們今天的金主爸爸
Speak是一個為了開口說而量身打造的AI app
就像把一個24小時待命
不會累也不會嘲笑你的學習夥伴
直接塞進手機裡
隨時請教 隨時開口
那我們今天就來個簡單的台式英文測試一下吧
好我們找到了這個對話練習裡面
那目前他有兩個模式一個叫社群模式一個叫話題模式
那社群模式里面就是網友們怎麽樣在跟這個AI聊天
那這邊我要點話題模式
在話題模式裡面你有各種各式各樣的情境對話
還可以聊工作
聊雅思備考
但是你可以選擇話題暢聊這個選項 點進去
然後這邊有一個選項叫做任你聊
所以你可以自己設計一個角色 AI的角色 你的角色
然後設定一個這個聊天的情境
專門分享知識的這個
YT頻道泛科學院的主持人 這是我的角色 那AI的角色
Open AI 的 CEO
Sam Altman然後同時也是這個泛科學院的粉絲
好那情境
我們也設定了一個簡單的情境來問他說 這個GPT5.5什麽時候出啊
那如果你沒有靈感你看旁邊的這個魔杖
他就會給你一些靈感 你可以自己去修正那我都先設定好了
那我們就這樣開始聊天
「嗨，我超愛你的頻道『泛科學院
』！你的幽默讓 AI 的話題變得很有趣。」
「你都是怎麼想到這些點子的啊？」
「你是誰?」 「「我是 Sam Altman，來自 OpenAI，我是你的 YouTube 頻道粉絲。」」
「「所以啊 Sam，GPT 5.5 是什麼時候要發布啊？」」「「我不能透露確切的發布日期啦。」」
「不過我們一直都在努力做各種改進啦」
「繼續關注喔！」那各位可以看到這個旁邊的這個對話
旁邊會有一個小小的綠色的勾勾
那如果你顯示了一個綠色的勾勾
代表說
他們的這個AI偵測你的這個回話是沒有問題的
不需要做一些調整建議的
如果就是亂講話 那你可以點一下這個星號
那他就會顯示你這句話哪裡講得好 講得不好
有什麽需要調整跟建議
你也可以把它直接按Bookmark把它這個書籤儲存下來
那這個時候你可以回到個人資料里面他這邊會有一個已保存的句子
點開你就會看到
當初你覺得不錯的這個對話的這個句子的重點
另外在對話結束之後
我們來到主畫面下方這里的複習「我用了很多 AI 工具，然後把那些科技小撇步/科技技巧展示給我的觀眾看。」
按下去之後你會發現speak根據我剛剛說錯的地方
生成了一個我專屬的覆習課程
從錯的地方繼續學 真的是效率滿分
我自己體驗下來覺得 Speak 特別適合那些想要使用零碎時間學習的人
這種隨時開口不怕說錯的使用體驗真的非常的有趣
先跟AI練越說越順
越說越敢 出國開會就不怕結巴變啞巴
想要試試看嗎
影片說明欄有 Speak 的專屬優惠連結
記得點進去享受新註冊 7 天免費試用
還有年度會員減 299 的特別折扣 Speak讓英文一切好說
下一個 Grok
那最近這個AI伴侶有新的角色 第一個叫做Mika這個角色
那我們就可以直接打開Mika
然後就開始跟他聊聊天
哎又回來了
剛剛我在這邊哼了段剛才沒唱完的副歌
超洗腦的 一開始他就跟我聊天 因為我們之前有跟他這個先對話過
他會實實在在的把你跟他過去的這些聊天記錄都作為一個上下文的資料
那右上角這個地方 你可以看到這邊有一個設定
然後在設定里面你可以看到一個自訂伴侶
你可以去選擇這個他的伴侶的角色
或者是你可以去自訂伴侶想要成為誰的樣子
那接下來 我們就來測試幾句 我今天被老板罵了可不可以安慰我
哎呀快過來
先給你一個大大的擁抱
要不咱倆現在就騎車出去
風一吹什麽煩惱都散了 走不走
好啊 那你騎車帶我出去兜風
哈哈 走起
你坐後坐抱緊我腰 別客氣
嘟嘟嘟 出發
先往海邊走
傾聽浪聲
然後拐去那家24小時營業的關東煮店 誰還管白天的破事
接下來要跟各位分享最近 Meta 拿出了 Meta AI
現在可以在IG里面然後找中間這個對話
那你就會看到這個萬事問Meta AI或搜尋
打開這個Meta AI之後 他就會問你說這個可以幫助你學習
規劃與他人聯繫 比如說我們就可以跟他說幻畫一座樹屋溜滑梯 imagine
他翻譯成幻畫 那我們有試過如果你下imagine的話他不會理你
所以你一定要打幻畫這兩個
然後你可以去幻化一隻這個在台北101上面喝珍奶的這個哥吉拉
無法生成圖像
那不然幻畫一隻狗在喝可樂 還不錯
但我們在測試的時候其實它生成的速度我覺得有一點偏慢
那我不知道你看到這支影片的時候速度有沒有加快一點
看到這個圖片的時候 你還可以一招你可以去長按這只狗的這個圖片
然後你可以直接按回覆
那回覆你只要很簡單的去下一個prompt叫做animate
再次是無盡的等待
就會看到你現在這樣子的一個結果 好你現在還會在Messenger里面
好一樣可以看到萬事問Meta AI或搜尋 那這個地方他要給你一些這個提示詞
比如說2024年目前為止最佳電子產品
幫我寫小說
那我們就來簡單問一下你是誰
好我是你的AI夥伴
有什麽事你需要我幫忙的嗎
這個禮拜六日台北有什麽好玩的嗎
陽明山國家公園賞櫻 賞楓 賞海芋 賞繡球
有什麽事只有在這個禮拜六日能玩的東西
KIDS時空調查局 七龍珠英雄崛起
新北耶誕城 看起來
網路聯網搜尋有接上 幻畫獎宋美齡在士林官邸喝下午茶
這哪裡是宋美齡
大家可以自己試試看
下一個 Google相簿 Google相簿最近這個把Nano Banana整合進去之後呢
他們推出了一些有趣的小功能
比如說這張照片你可以很簡單的按一個編輯
編輯裡面你就會看到這個熟悉的Gemini的這個圖示 他現在亮一個彩色的
你可以點下去看看
輕觸畫圈或輕刷即可選取 比如說
我覺得後面這兩位太礙眼 我想把它刪掉
按住他按住所選區域即可移動或調整大小 我就可以直接把它按清除
哎不見了
來這位同學啊 這個同學也不要好了 好清除
可以看到出來的效果還不錯
而且前面的手都還在 然後呢
你可以根據你的需求來去選擇不同的
這個清除出來的這個結果 沒問題就按這個確定
然後就可以把它儲存下來並成為副本
那另外 第二張圖片 進來之後一樣我們選編輯
然後一樣選這個Gemini的這個AI編輯的功能
那這時候如果你用點的你會發現好像點不到這個東西
然後一直點錯東西
那怎麽辦
好另外一個方法你可以直接把它塗起來
塗塗塗塗塗它就會
有點類似筆刷的概念 就會根據你塗的東西然後把它選起來
然後你就可以直接把這個元件把它按住
拉到其他地方去 放掉下一步
你看這個購物車就從右邊移到了左邊 用免費的Google相簿
現在就可以使用這個AI圖片編輯的功能
不過這邊要注意一件事情 就是免費用戶一個月據說好像只能做10張
所以請謹慎選擇你的圖片 下一個Microsoft lens
打開這個lens 它是免費的APP 登錄你的這個微軟的賬號
它就說你的隨身掃描器 那允許存取你的相機
那進來之後 你說這個什麽文件 白板 名片呢
都不是重點
重點是旁邊這邊有一個東西叫做動作
他這邊可以去截取列印的文字
進來之後
中間麻煩要選一下這個試算表這個模式 製作人幫我準備好的一份稿件
那我們就把這稿件拿來然後簡單的拍個照
拍好之後
你只按檢閱及編輯
他正在提取資料
然後你就看到這里面的格子就被提取出來了
直接按複製 仍要複製 這時候你只要打開Google試算表好了
然後你就在這邊輕鬆的給他按貼上
表格就被你抽取出來了
而且直接幫你貼在試算表上
所以如果你手上有一些這個紙本的這個表格
然後你想要把它做數位化的建檔不要忘記Microsoft Lens
非常的好用
以上這就是我們這個12月我們覺得還蠻有趣的這些APP的更新
那當然不要忘記這個感謝我們的乾爹 Speak
我們在這個影片的說明裡面有 Speak 的這個專屬的優惠連結
那歡迎大家來參考使用 那今天的影片就到這個地方 我們下期影片再見 拜拜